Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour.
Je suis venu vous parler du conflit,
ou plutôt je suis venu
vous apporter du conflit.
Je vous parle pour qu’il y ait
plus de conflits dans vos vies,
plus de conflits dans vos familles,
plus de conflits avec vos amis,
plus de conflits, bien sûr, à votre
travail, avec vos collègues, vos chefs.
Mais pourquoi est-ce que j’ai
un projet aussi bizarre ?
Je veux plus de conflits dans le monde
pour qu'il y ait moins de violence.
Laissez-moi vous dire d’abord que
j’ai grandi dans une famille
où il y avait très peu de conflits,
une famille où, c’était l’époque -
je ne suis plus tout à fait un millénial -
une certaine éducation,
assez stricte, était de mise.
Dans cette éducation,
les enfants n’avaient pas
le droit de parler à table,
ils n’avaient pas le droit de réclamer
quoi que ce soit pour eux-mêmes,
ne répondaient pas à leurs parents.
Pas de conflit.
En plus de ça, j’avais un père colérique,
très colérique.
Il avait les colères
qu’on peut appeler homériques.
Elles étaient rarement dirigées
contre moi, mais ça me terrifiait.
Quand ça se passait, j’avais envie
de me cacher, de disparaître,
de devenir invisible.
Si j’étais là, je ne bougeais plus.
Sinon, j’allais me terrer dans ma chambre.
Soyons francs, je n’ai pas été
spécialement maltraité -
en tout cas, selon les standards de
l’époque - mais ça m’a fait violence.
Pas de conflit,
mais de la violence.
C’est sans doute ça
qui m’a amené à m’intéresser au sujet,
à accompagner des gens dans le
« oser le conflit » et à vous parler.
Et aujourd’hui,
j’ai trois choses à vous dire
et trois choses que j’aimerais
que vous reteniez.
La première, c’est que le conflit,
ce n’est pas de la violence.
La seconde, c’est qu’il n’y a pas
de vie sans conflit.
Et la troisième, c'est que le conflit,
parfois, c'est de la joie.
« Le conflit n’est pas la violence. »
Si vous ouvrez le dictionnaire, vous
verrez que « conflit », ça a deux sens.
D'abord, une lutte armée entre des États.
Laissons ça de côté.
Et le deuxième sens, c’est opposition,
désaccord, différend.
C’est à ça qu’on va s’intéresser.
Je vous propose une nouvelle définition.
Et cette nouvelle définition, c’est :
le conflit, c’est un désaccord
qui nécessite un ajustement.
Un désaccord qui nécessite un ajustement.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Avec mon épouse un après-midi.
Elle veut aller se promener,
moi, je veux rester à la maison.
Chacun peut aller de son côté, mais si
nous voulons passer l’après-midi ensemble,
alors il va falloir qu’on s’ajuste.
C'est un conflit, un tout petit conflit,
mais un conflit tout de même.
Laissez-moi aussi utiliser une métaphore.
J’ai un ami, Jean-Philippe,
qui est géophysicien à Caltech,
l’université de Californie,
où il étudie les tremblements de terre.
Il était de passage à Paris
il y a quelques années
et on était avec quelques amis à l’écouter
nous parler de ses recherches
et des endroits dans le monde
où il craignait que
des tremblements de terre surviennent
à plus ou moins brève échéance.
Je ne me souviens plus
des pays qu’il a cités,
mais je me souviens
qu’il n’y avait pas la Californie.
On lui a dit : « Et la Californie, alors ?
La faille de San Andréas, etc.
- Ah non, on n’est pas inquiets.
- Comment ça, pas inquiets ? Mais...
les films catastrophes,
les articles The Big One,
la réplique du grand tremblement de
terre de San Francisco au siècle dernier ?
- Non, non.
On n’est pas inquiets car à Los
Angeles, les 30 dernières années,
il y a eu plein de tremblements de terre,
plein de tremblements de terre. »
Au fond, quand vous y réfléchissez,
c’est quoi un tremblement de terre ?
Ce sont les plaques tectoniques, qui
sont comme les écailles de la Terre,
qui bougent indépendamment.
Et de temps en temps, il y en a une
qui veut aller à droite, l’autre à gauche,
Et ça coince.
Et de la tension s’accumule
dans le sous-sol,
s’accumule, s’accumule
et un beau matin, pouf,
une plaque passe au-dessus
de l’autre ou l’inverse.
Les immeubles qui sont
à la surface tombent
sauf si cet ajustement
se fait par petites touches
au fil des jours et des semaines.
C’est ce qui s’est passé.
Il y a eu plein de tremblements de terre
ces trente dernières années à Los Angeles.
Et au fond, le conflit,
c'est la même chose.
Notre sous-sol, ce sont nos tripes.
L’énergie qui s’accumule, ce sont
les frustrations, le ressentiment.
Et si nous purgeons cette énergie
que nous avons en nous régulièrement,
alors notre vie et nos relations
restent debout, comme les immeubles.
Mais si nous évitons le conflit, alors
un beau jour, la violence fait irruption
et détruit notre vie et nos relations.
Éviter le conflit, c’est acheter
de la tranquillité aujourd’hui
contre de la catastrophe demain.
Oser le conflit, assumer le conflit,
c’est s’assurer,
pour les jours qui viennent,
pour les années qui viennent,
une vie paisible.
Le conflit, ça n'est pas de la violence.
C'est même l'inverse.
Deuxième message
que j’aimerais vous transmettre,
en tout cas, partager avec vous,
c’est qu’il n’y a pas de vie sans conflit.
Je vais encore vous raconter une histoire.
Une toute petite histoire faite
de toutes petites choses du quotidien.
Je sors de chez moi, je vais
prendre le métro - j’habite à Paris -
et je rencontre des amis
que je n’ai pas vus depuis longtemps.
Ah ! Chic !
Je suis content de les voir.
Je m’approche d’eux,
je vais à leur rencontre.
En m’approchant,
je m’aperçois qu’ils ont l’air occupés,
ou même préoccupés.
Ils ont l'air de discuter sérieusement.
Peut-être même qu’ils se disputent.
Je ne vais pas les déranger,
je vais les laisser.
Je suis là
dans l’impuissance.
J’ai un désir et j’y renonce.
A l’inverse, je peux aller les voir :
« Comment ça va ? Je suis content »
et bla bla bla bla.
Je leur tape dans le dos.
Mais peut-être étaient-ils
en train de se disputer.
J'arrive au mauvais moment.
J'arrive un peu comme un chien
dans un jeu de quilles.
Et peut-être même qu’ils vont me rejeter.
« Tu vois bien que
ça n’est pas le moment. »
Là, je suis dans la toute-puissance.
J’ai un désir
et je l’assouvis sans prendre
en considération la situation de mes amis.
Entre ces deux extrêmes,
l’impuissance et la toute-puissance,
il y a un point commun.
Et ce point commun,
c’est que je fais tout seul.
Je décide tout seul de ne pas y aller,
ou je décide tout seul
que « Non, non, il n’y a
pas de problème, j’y vais »,
Et ce « tout seul »,
c’est le symptôme de la violence.
Vous savez, la violence est
le fait d’assouvir un désir
ou de satisfaire un besoin par la force.
Et dans ces conditions, l'autre disparaît.
L’exemple presque ultime - là,
on n’est pas dans les toutes choses -
le grand exemple, c’est le viol.
L'autre disparaît derrière le désir
de celui qui fait violence.
Dans mon histoire, c’est la même chose,
bien sûr, à une autre échelle,
en tout petit.
Dans un cas,
je me fais violence à moi-même,
et dans l’autre, je fais violence,
même si c’est modeste, sur autrui.
Alors, il existe heureusement un chemin
intermédiaire, un chemin entre ces deux -
comme un chemin de crête - entre ces
deux violences, un chemin de puissance.
C'est très simple.
« Salut, je vous dérange,
vous êtes occupés ? »
Peut-être qu’ils vont me dire :
« Oui » , « Non », « Viens »,
« Ce n’est pas le moment »
Qu’importe,
je les aurai dérangés un petit peu, mais
là , je commence à fabriquer du « nous ».
Je commence à fabriquer du « ensemble ».
Je vais chercher du consentement,
ce qui est tout
le contraire de la violence.
On le voit dans cette petite histoire
que violence et conflit sont des choses
qui viennent dans la moindre
des situations de la vie.
La violence et le conflit sont
potentiellement partout dans nos vies.
Quoi que vous fassiez,
quelque désir que vous ayez,
quelque besoin que vous ayez à satisfaire,
dès que vous faites mouvement,
comme les plaques tectoniques
font mouvement sur le monde,
alors vous vous exposez
au besoin d’autrui.
Vous vous exposez au conflit.
Vous ne pouvez pas vivre
ni entreprendre quoi que ce soit
sans déranger autrui.
Vivre, c’est déranger le monde.
Et déranger le monde, c’est
s’ouvrir à la potentialité du conflit.
Deuxième message :
il n’y a pas de vie sans conflit.
Le troisième message sur lequel
je vais terminer, qui est
« Le conflit, c’est de la joie »,
c’est le plus difficile,
mais ce sera le plus court.
Si vous m’avez suivi,
si vous êtes d’accord avec moi
sur ce que je viens de dire,
vous serez d’accord pour dire
qu’éviter le conflit,
c’est éviter de confronter
nos besoins à ceux des autres.
Et si je vis avec quelqu'un, que ce soit
professionnellement, personnellement,
sans jamais dévoiler mes besoins, ni aller
au conflit pour découvrir les siens,
alors nous allons avoir
une relation superficielle.
Si, au contraire, j’assume le conflit,
j’assume de mettre notre relation
au risque de nos besoins divergents,
alors si nous avons le bonheur
de traverser cette épreuve,
nous saurons que nous sommes capables
ensemble de traverser les tempêtes
et nous en saurons un peu plus
sur ce que l’autre a dans le cœur.
C'est pourquoi le conflit est un chemin
vers l'intimité des êtres.
C'est un chemin vers la joie
de la rencontre véritable.
Le conflit, c'est de la joie
et c’est pourquoi je vous souhaite
à tous de merveilleux conflits.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)